why is pluto not a planet anymore
does this upset you or uh has justice
finally been served
so i get asked this all the time i think
all all planetary scientists get asked
about pluto especially by kids who
would just love for pluto to still be a
planet um
but the the reality is um when we first
discovered pluto it was it was a unique
object in the outer solar system and we
thought
you know we were adding a planet to the
inventory of planets that we had and
then over time
it became clear that pluto was not a
unique
large object in the outer solar system
that there were actually
many of these um and as we started
discovering more and more of them we
realized that the concept of pluto being
a planet
um didn't make sense unless maybe we
added all the rest of them as planets so
you know you could have imagined
actually a different direction that this
could have gone where all the other
objects that were discovered in that
belt or at least all the ones let's say
above
above a certain size became planets
instead of pluto being
declassified but we
were now aware of many objects out there
in the outer solar system and what's
called the kuiper belt that are
of the same size or in some cases even
larger than pluto
so the the declassification was really
just a realization that it was not
in the same category as the other
planets in the solar system and we
basically needed to refine our
our definition in such a way that took
into account that there's this this
belt of debris out there in the outer
solar system of things with a range of
sizes
um is there a hope for clear
categorization
of what is a planet and not do or is it
all just gray area when you study
planets when you study moons satellites
of those planets
is there lines that are cl that could be
cleanly drawn
or is it just a giant mess this is all
like a fluid
let's say not mess but it's like fluid
uh of what is a planet what is the moon
of a planet what is debris
what is asteroids all that gonna so
there
are technically clear definitions that
were set down by the
iu the international astronomy union
um is it size related like what are the
parameters based on so the parameters
are that it has to orbit the sun which
was essentially to rule out satellites
of course this was
a not very forward-thinking definition
because it technically means that all
extrasolar planets according to that
definition are not planets
um so it has to order the orbit the sun
it has to be
large enough that its gravity has caused
it to become spherical in shape
um which also applies to satellites and
also applies to pluto the third part of
the definition is the thing that really
rules out everything else which is that
it has to has
have cleared out its orbital path and
because pluto orbits in a belt of
material it doesn't satisfy
that stipulation why didn't it clear out
the path it's not big enough
right knock everybody out of the way um
and this actually is not the first time
it has happened
so ceres when it was discovered ceres is
the largest asteroid in the asteroid
belt
and it was originally considered a
planet when it was first discovered and
it went through
exactly the same story history where
people
actually realized that it was just one
of many asteroids in the asteroid belt
region and then
it got declassified to an asteroid and
now it's back to a dwarf planet
so there is a lot of reclassification so
to me as somebody who studies
solar system objects i
just personally don't care my level of
interest and something has nothing to do
with
what it's classified as so my favorite
objects in the solar system are all
moons and frequently when i
talk about them i refer to them as
planets because to me they are
planets they have volcanoes they have
geology they have atmospheres they're
planet-like
worlds and so the distinction is not
super meaningful to me but i
it is important just for having a
general framework for
for understanding and talking about
things to have a precise definition
so you don't have a special romantic
like appreciation of a moon versus a
planet versus an asteroid it's just an
object that flies out there and doesn't
really matter
what the categorization is because
there's movies about asteroids and stuff
and then there's like and then there's
movies about you know
the moon whatever it's a really good
movie
you know there's something about moons
that uh that's almost like
an outlier like you think of of a moon
as a thing that's the secret part and
the planet
is like the more like vanilla regular
part
none of that you don't have any of that
no i actually do i really satellites are
the moons are my favorite things in the
solar system and i think part of
what you're saying i agree from
maybe a slightly different perspective
which is from the perspective of
exploration
we've spent a lot of time sending
spacecraft missions to planets we had a
mission to jupiter we had a mission to
saturn we have plenty of missions to
mars and missions to venus
i think that exploration of the moons in
the outer solar system is
the next frontier of solar system
exploration
you